but just one bad tweet break a brand or
is it more about the overall quality of
content yeah Rebecca I think this is the
most uh this is the most interesting
thing I am dumbfounded by the lack of
knowledge that no one tweet guys BP oil
spilt all of the [ __ ] oil in the
world into the Gulf of Mexico and you
[ __ ] still fill up your car with it
and so do I there's a complete lack of
understanding of what cripples and
actual business the fact that
billion-dollar [ __ ] brands same room
scared that one tweet that wasn't so
good like woe is me we're gonna you're
not going out of business
idiot so you can see I'm excited about
this issue I believe intent Trump's all
I believe intent Trump's all we're all
gonna make a mistake I actually believe
that saying you're sorry in today's
society when none of us actually want to
say it is so powerful that sometimes I
think about doing things wrong just so I
could come out and say I'm sorry because
I think it's an actual net net positive
win for me and so yeah I mean I I think
this is a ludicrous conversation of
course you're gonna make mistakes
that's what happens when 22 year old
interns are managing your social media
and you know and that's what's gonna
happen and that's okay and you have to
go out and own it and say you're sorry I
promise you all the brands that are
worried about their tweets they need to
worry about their product they've got
bigger issues at hand than some random
tweet when they got a piece of [ __ ]
product you guys like that one huh all
right I'm paying attention